welcome to analog I'm your host Lisa
foils and I have titled this episode
hack drive play we're taking on watchdog
since the day this open-world action
game was announced people have been
dying to play it and now it's finally
here for pretty much every console and
PC and yeah people have been going crazy
for it but if you went a little too
crazy and you finished it already and we
have got more for you here are games
similar to watch dogs watch dogs is all
about the hacking you're in a futuristic
Chicago where technology is both your
tool and your weapon well give it an
even more futuristic feel and you're in
Deus Ex Human Revolution territory
similar to watch dogs human revolution
is flexible you can approach objectives
in many different ways if you need to
get into a guarded building you can
shoot your way through be stealthy with
silent takedowns find a secret passage
or yes hack open a door as you progress
you can augment your body in ways that
compliment your preferred play style the
hacking mechanic is much better than say
Mass Effect and lets you earn XP
currency and programs to help you hack
even better this manipulation of
technology along with paying attention
to details logging into computers and
marking enemies to keep tabs on them all
feels very similar to watchdogs but
while watchdogs takes place in Chicago
human revolution takes place all over
the world
you'll Globetrotter and see how the
world has changed due to technology and
human augmentation the source of the
whole games conspiracy it's funny Adam
Jensen is from future Detroit and Aiden
Pearce is from future Chicago I don't
even want to know what future Las Vegas
is gonna be like
driving in watchdogs is some real
destructive Arkady fun and if you liked
those button prompts that set off
explosions and mess with the traffic
lights then you need to give
split-second a try yes it's a racing
game but it shares one glorious element
with watchdogs the ability to press a
button when prompted and wreak
environmental havoc on your opponents
sometimes you can even alter the entire
racetrack in watchdogs you can trigger
pipes beneath the street to explode or
switch a green light to a red light for
burnout where the intersection crashes
in split second the triggers or power
plays are similar but the longer you
wait to cause chaos the Marcius you can
cause the better you drive ie
drafting drifting and perfect cornering
the more energy you accumulate there are
three bars bars one and two will cause
things like barrels to roll on to your
competitor or maybe open up a race
winning shortcut while that third bar
can cause airplanes to land on the track
or a traffic control tower to smash the
other cars it's fast it's furious and
that is pretty much the whole game just
remember to check yourself before you
wreck yourself because no seriously
sometimes launching those power plays
will just destroy your own car yes
everyone says watchdogs is just gta5
with hacking and while I agree I would
rather recommend Saints Row
don't lie you love those watchdog's
minigames running around grabbing 8-bit
coins terrorizing the city as a giant
spider you know not taking things so
seriously if you're looking for a GTA
parody go for Saints Row 1 & 2 if you
want complete off the rails stupidity
try Saints Row 3 & 4 while I appreciate
a good dubstep gun doesn't everybody
my favorite is Saints Row too much like
watchdogs is an open-world playground
and the missions are very diverse some
are standard assassinations while others
have you riding around on a flaming ATV
running over citizens to add time to
your clock pre standard Saints Row also
lets you customize your character in
pretty much every way shape and form
including the sound of your voice and
your ridiculous catchphrases if there's
one thing Saints Row does right it's
never forgetting that this is a game and
it's supposed to be fun it takes comedic
liberties that detract from any kind of
serious story and reminds you that it's
all fake but is that really a bad thing
I mean watchdogs is trying to convince
us that an entire city is run on one
operating system it's ludicrous but
somehow it works
Saints Row also to complete the entire
story via online co-op so you and a
friend can both terrorize Stillwater
with katanas and pimp Kane's send me a
tweet Ally's foils let me know which
games you think are like watchdogs what
you ate for lunch what your cat is doing
right now hey I want to hear it all
whatever is on your mind and then come
back and see me again next week for
another analog